hey guys meet Ahmed our new interpreter
money isn't the reason he wants this job
and Taliban killed his son
it's a very simple story about two men
from completely different backgrounds
deciding to do the right thing for three
weeks this family believed you are dead
we owe that man your life it's really
about one man we're paying a debt and
how War can induce a form of
selflessness Ahmed and his family are in
trouble I am gonna have to get him out
myself
the relationship between John and Ahmed
was born out of necessity but it keeps
growing from the circumstances that they
face
this movie goes beyond the uniform
into the unspoken relationship between
two human beings you think I have a
choice
there is no choice
[Music]